ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนะเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
ตบมืออะไรคะดีใจค่ะ
ดีใจเอาดีใจเจอกันเย้ดีใจไม่เสียใจใช่ไหม
ไปซอดีใจดีใจดีใจก็ยิ้มค่ะ
เสียใจก็อื้ออื้อ
ร้องไห้นะคะวันนี้ครูหญิงดีใจดีใจวันอะไร
ค่ะอันอาทิตย์ค่ะ
วันอาทิตย์ก็เลยเย้ดีใจ
วันที่เท่าไหร่ค่ะวันที่ 3 พี่น้องข้าวัน
ที่ 3 เดือนอะไรคะเดือนเมษายน
เดือนเมษายน
ปีพตเท่าไหร่คะปีพ.ศ
2565 ค่ะดีคอยต.ค.เท่าไหร่คะ
200 ต่อไม่ใช่ค่ะ
022  022 ค่ะลิปซิงผู้หญิงน่ะ
นักเรียนไม่นะคะเปลี่ยนมั้ยลิปซิ้งนะคะ
คู๋ลืมสิ่งโอเคนะคะ
แล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้เวลา 6 โมง
51 นาทีค่ะ
06:51 นะคะเนี่ยเสื้อยี่ห้อคลิปที่แหละ
เมื่อวานนี้ครูเอ๋เล่นเกมเย้เกมคู่หญิง
ปวดหัว
คลิปนี้วันนี้ไม่มีเกมไม่มีเกมค่ะครูเอ๋
แต่มีคำถามไหมคะ
มีคำถาม
มีคำถามนะคะมีรูปให้ครูเอ๋ดูไหมคะให้คุย
นี่ค่ะมีรูปครูหญิงมีรูปมีรูป
อ๋อมีรูปอะไรครับรูปหลบคำ
ดูนะคะโอเคค่ะแล้วครูเอ๋แล้วคุณก็จะมีคำ
ถามค่ะครูเอ๋เอ๋ถามครูเอ๋ใช่ไหมคะใส่ค่ะ
นักเรียนก็มาดู
ฟังครูหญิงถามครูเอ๋นักเรียนถามได้ไหมคะ
ไม่ได้ค่ะ
ครูเอ๊ะถามได้ไหมคะได้ค่ะถามได้ผู้หญิง
ถามได้นั้นเรียนห้ามถาม
ให้ไม่ได้ค่ะครูหญิงซึ่ง
เป็นเปล่าเปียนะคะเดี๋ยวครูหญิงขาดผู้
หญิงมีรูปให้ครูเอ๋ดูแล้วก็จะถามครูเอ๋
ได้ขา
ลิงกิ้ 1 หรอ
เห็นไหมครับตัวเองอะไรคะครูเอ๋
งวัวค่ะอ้าววัวขลุ่ยจะถามครูเอว่าวัว
เนี่ยนะครับเป็นสัตว์บกหรือสัตว์น้ำอ่ะมี
ตัวเนี่ยเป็นสัตว์ใช่ไหมคะเป็นสัตว์ค่ะ
ผู้หญิงเป็นคน
ครูเอ๋เป็นคน
นักเรียนเป็นคนค่ะอ่ะแก้วเป็นอะไรคะเป็น
สิ่งของแก้วเป็นสิ่งของนะคะ
ปากกาเป็นอะไรคะเป็นสิ่งของเป็นสิ่งของ
วัวเป็นสัตว์ค่ะเป็นสัตว์เป็นสัตว์นะคะ
แต่ครูหญิงขาวว่าเป็นสัตว์
บกหบหรือสัตว์น้ำ f เบิ้ลกับน้ำเป็นยังไง
เดี๋ยวผู้หญิงให้ดูค่ะลายค่ะ
มีค่ะ
แค่แค่อ่ะเดี๋ยวนะคะอาโก a คอร์ดเขียนอ่ะ
เอเอเนี่ยอุ่นผู้หญิงเห็นไหมคะคุณเขียน
ข้างบนสีดำก็ได้ค่ะมันจะเห็นโอเคสักครู่
สักคู่อ่ะตรงนี้ใช่ไหมคะค่ะมีคลิปภาพ a
กับภาพดีนะตาล
ครับ a เป็นบกใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะบกภักดีเป็น
น้ำใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะน้ำแล้วก็น้ำ
มีปลุกมีน้ำฮะที่นี่เมื่อกี้คุณหญิงถามกู
อีกว่าอะไรนะผู้หญิงถามว่ามั่วนะคะวัว
เนี่ยเป็นสัตว์บก a
หรือสัตว์น้ำวัวหรออ่ะ
วัวเป็นหน้า
เด็กค่ะไทยค่ะวัวเป็นสัตว์บบอานวยอยู่ที่
26 แล้วก็น้ำนะคะระบบน้ำ
วัว
งั้นกูเอ๋ต้องคิดใช่ไหมจะเป็นสัตว์บกหรือ
สัตว์น้ำราคาให้ค่ะ
เอาบกกันน้ำออกไปค่ะเข้าใจแล้วเดี๋ยวบอก
หรือน้ำ
หรือน้ำผู้หญิงคู๋เอาอันนี้ได้ไหมอะไร
ครับโอเคมีปากกา
ปากกาผู้หญิงผู้หญิงเอา Share  screen
ออกได้ได้ค่ะ
คู๋อันนี้อันนี้บกอันนี้น้ำโอเคไหมเอาสี
เขียว 6 ไหมเอาเปลี่ยนเป็นเขียวหรอชายๆสี
เขียว
ชื่อสัตว์บก
สีฟ้าสัตว์น้ำมันใกล้ๆกันนะผู้หญิงโอเค
งั้นสีแดงก็ได้ค่ะสีน้ำตาล
ผู้หญิง
ตาตาคุหญิงโอเคมั้ยคิดว่าไม่โอเคดูสีไม่
เข้าใจสีน้ำตาลบกสีฟ้าน้ำโอเคไหมคะโอเค
ค่ะ
ห้วเป็นสัตว์บกค่ะกลัวสัตว์บกค่ะอ่ะครู
เอ๋คะสัตว์ตัวนี้อะไรคะปลาฉลามอ่ะปลาฉลาม
เป็นสัตว์บกหรือสัตว์น้ำสัตว์บกหรือสัตว์
น้ำสัตว์น้ำหรือสัตว์บกสัตว์บกหรือสัตว์
รักเต้นตามจังหวะครูเอ๋มี
สัตว์
สีฟ้าค่ะสัตว์น้ำไก่ค่ะเนาะปลาฉลามเป็น
สัตว์น้ำสระน้ำ
ไปต่อไปเอาอีกเอาอีกสัตว์ตัวนี้แมวหรอคะ
ชื่ออะไรคะไม่ใช่แมวไม่ใช่แมว
เสือ
ไปค่ะเสือเสือเป็นสัตว์บกหรือสัตว์น้ำคะ
สัตว์บกสัตว์น้ำสีน้ำตาลสัตว์บกสีฟ้า
สัตว์น้ำสื่อเสือเสือว่ายน้ำ
ได้หน้าเสือเก่งของเสือว่ายน้ำได้แต่เสือ
ไม่นอนในน้ำลายเสือสีน้ำตาลนี่แหละ
[เพลง]
เสือเป็นสัตว์บกค่ะต่อไปค่ะ
ใช่ค่ะเสือเป็นสัตว์บกเก่งมากค่ะครูเอ๋
สาวๆ
สัตว์ตัวนี้เรียกว่าอะไรคะ
แคะค่ะน่ะแพะเป็นสัตว์
อันนี้อะไรอ่ะเขาเขาแพะมีข่าวแล้วตรงนี้
อะไร
เรา
มีเขามีเครามีเครามีเขาก็มีเขามีเครามี
เครามีเขานะคะมีมั่วเลยค่ะ
โอเคผู้หญิงถามว่าอะไรผู้หญิงถามว่าแพ้
เป็นสัตว์บกหรือว่าสัตว์น้ำคะครูเอ๋เอ๋
ชื่อสัตว์บกค่ะใจค่ะแพทเป็นสัตว์บก
คู่เอกเก่งมากเก่งมากนักเรียนเก่งไหม
นักเรียนดูแล้วก็คิดสัตว์สัตว์อะไรบก
สัตว์บกหรือว่าสัตว์น้ำนะคะสัตว์บกสัตว์
น้ำค่ะไปค่ะเอาอีกครูเอ๋คะสัตว์ตัวนี้
เรียกว่าอะไรล่ะชื่ออะไรคะหรือว่าเรียก
ว่าอะไรคะเรียกว่าอะไรก็โอเคชื่ออะไรก็
โอเคค่ะหมาอะ
ค่ะมาหมาเป็นสัตว์บกหรือว่าสัตว์น้ำคะหมา
เป็นสัตว์บกสัตว์น้ำสัตว์บกสัตว์บกค่ะใจ
ค่ะหมา
นี้เป็นสัตว์บบเป็นสัตว์บกนะคะหมอเหวงชอบ
หมาไหมคะ
ชอบหมา
นอนกอดหมาโอเคอ่าผู้หญิงไม่ชอบหมาคะไม่
ชอบหมาค่ะผู้หญิงน่ารัก
มาชอบ
หมีลิ้นแล้วก็เลียตายๆๆเลียหน้าคู๋ได้เลย
อ่ะ
หมาชอบเลียมากๆโอเคมีอีกไหมคะมีค่ะครูเอก
คะสัตว์ตัวนี้เรียกว่าอะไรคะ
เฮ้ยกูคงโง่มีหางม้วนม้วน
ก็มีปาก
ปาก
อ๋อคู๋รู้แล้วใครครับว่าม้าน้ำค่ะม้าๆ
ชัยค่ะครูเองคะเดี๋ยวยังไม่ได้ถามใจเย็นๆ
ม้าน้ำ
ไม่รู้แล้วอ่ะม้านางน้ำเป็นสัตว์บบหรือ
ว่าสัตว์น้ำ
ม้าหนาวม้าน้ำม้าแล้วก็น้ำก็ต้องสัตว์น้ำ
ค่ะครูหญิงไทยค่ะ
เนาะม้าน้ำเป็นสัตว์น้ำสัตว์น้ำกินได้ไหม
กินได้ไหมคะม้าน้ำ
คนไทยไม่ทั้งสิ้น 5 กะบางคนกินสำหรับแข็ง
แรงจริงหรอคะคุณ
ผู้หญิงไม่รู้เลย
ไม่ใช่คนไทยก็เอกเคยเห็นมาหา
โอเคตัวต่อไปค่ะไรเอ่ย
ตัดตัวนี้เรียกว่าอะไรคะครูเอ๋
สิงโตค่ะโอ้วสิงโต
สิงโตมีผมใช่ไหมคะเขาเรียกผมไหมคะตรงนี้
แผงคอออแผงคอใหญ่มากผมแผงขนนี่
สิงโต
สิงโตเป็นสัตว์บกหรือสัตว์น้ำสิงโต
สิสีฟ้าเนี่ยสีฟ้าสัตว์น้ำสีน้ำตาล
ขอบกสิงโตสีอะไรคะสิงโตสีน้ำตาลสีน้ำตาล
งั้นสิงโตเป็นสัตว์บกค่ะ I คะค่ะ
เก่งมากขอบคุณค่ะ
กูอ่ะเก่งมากค่ะต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋ช่อสัตว์
ตัวนี้
อะไรคะ
พุ่งค่ะ
ทำไมตอบไม่หญิงคิดครูเอ๋ชอบ
ไปทองรู้่คะตรงนี้ของกุ้งเรียกอะไรคะหนวด
ไหมเอาใช่ใช่หนวดกุ้งหนวดกุ้งแล้วตรงนี้
ล่ะคะ 1  2  3  4  5  6  7 ขากุ้ง
ขาวกุ้ง
ผู้
ใหญ่สันทำไมถามกุ้งมากๆต้องเองไม่ชอบเลย
ถามกุ้งมากๆมีริอ่อนวันที่ไม่มีค่ะไม่มี
ไอแอกุ้งเป็นสัตว์บกหรือสัตว์น้ำนะคะผู้
หญิงอาจถ้าสีน้ำตาลเนี่ยสัตว์บกใช่ไหมคะ
สีฟ้าเนี่ยสัตว์น้ำกุ้งครูหญิงหนังสีน้ำ
ตาลน่ะแต่ไม่ใช่สัตว์บอก
ขอบคุณค่ะคุณหญิงสัตว์น้ำ
จ่ายกุ้งเป็นสัตว์น้ำอยู่ในน้ำ
อยู่ในน้ำสัตว์น้ำ
รู๋คะมีอะไรอีกคะมีนี่นี่ค่ะอะไร
ฮ่าๆมี
สัตว์ตัวนี้เรียกว่าอะไรคะครูเอ๋
เรียกว่ากบค่ะจบกบ
อันอาจ
โกหก
roue คะกบเป็นสัตว์บกหรือสัตว์น้ำ
นักเรียน
โกะเป็นสัตว์บก
หรือสัตว์น้ำ
โอ้ย
กบอยู่บนบกได้ไหมคะได้ค่ะกบอยู่ในน้ำได้
ไหมคะได้ค่ะอ้าวแล้วจบเป็นเวลาเวลากบตัว
เล็กๆกบต้องอยู่ในน้ำอาล่าแจกจบโตกบมาบน
บกโอเคอยู่ในน้ำโอเค
น้ำบกน้ำ
r-cooh ผู้หญิงกบ
ครึ่งนะ
ครึ่งบกครึ่งน้ำ
ใช่ข้าวใช่หรอใช่ค่ะ
กบเป็นสัตว์ครึ่งบกครึ่งน้ำอ๋อถ้าเป็น
สัตว์ครึ่งบกครึ่งน้ำอยู่บนบกโอเคอยู่ใน
น้ำโอเคไม่ตายไม่ตายนอนในน้ำโอเคนอนทำ
โอเคโตก็
กดแล้วให้ไม่เหมือนกุ้งค่ะกุ้งขึ้นมาบนบก
ตายค่ะพี่กบก็ไม่เหมือนสิงโตสิงโตลงไปนอน
ในน้ำไม่ได้ถ้าก็ครึ่งบกครึ่งน้ำยังไม่
หมดค่ะยังไม่หมดยังไม่ยังมีอีกล่ะคะมีค่ะ
นี่ค่ะครูเอ๋จะรอนี้อุ้ยเรียกว่าอะไรคะ
เอาตัวนี้ใช่ไหมตอนนี้ตัวนี้ตัวนี้เลยค่ะ
แบบนี้ค่ะเก๋ปลาหมึกยักษ์โอ้วปลาหมึก
ยักษ์มีอะไรคะครูเอ๋ 1  2  3  4  5  6  7
มิ้นอวดค่ะ
อวดเนาะจริงๆขาขานะแต่เราพูดหนวดนะหาน้อย
อร่อยค่ะอร่อยเหมือนหนวดกุ้งกับหนวดค่ะรอ
อันนี้ก็เป็นหนวดหนวดไหนกินโตก็มีหนวด
เหรอคะคู๋สิงโตผู้หญิงมีมีๆนี่ใช่ไหมคะ 1
1  2  3 ค่ะเสือมีหนวดเสือเสือ
เห็นชัดเนาะมีเสือนี่ก็ไม่โหลดเรื่อง
หนึ่งสองสามสี่หนวดเสือ
ปลาหมึกยักษ์ก็มีหนวดค่ะหนวดหนวดอ่ะครู
เอกคะปลาหมึกยักษ์เป็นสัตว์บกหรือสัตว์
น้ำ
ไอ้คิวดีสัตว์น้ำค่ะใครค่ะอยู่ในน้ำว่าย
น้ำมึงใครนวดว่ายน้ำเหรอคะคู๋
room ครูเอ๋เอ๋กินลาหมึกยักษ์กินหวดปลา
หมึกยักษ์ค่ะกินหนวดยินหนวดถ้าชอบหนวดปลา
หมึกยะแล้วก็คัน
หนวดกุ้ง
หนวดกุ้งกินไหมคะไม่กินมั้ยกิน
หนวดปลาหมึกกิน in นะคะต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋
เป็นสัตว์น้ำไปแล้วสัตว์ตัวนี้เรียกว่า
อะไรคะปลาโลมาอ๊า
[เพลง]
เอามือมาโลมามาร้องเพลงได้เอกเคยฟังโรมา
ร้องเพลง
โอโห้เก่งนะโลมาเก่งสาย 3 ไม่ใช่ครูเอ๋
ไม่ใช่ครูหญิงนะคะ
มีอีกนะคะมีอีกไม่มีค่ะครูเอ๋อร่อยตัวนี้
เรียกว่าอะไรคะหมีค่ะ
หนีเป็นสัตว์บกหรือสัตว์น้ำดูสีดูสีนัก
เรียนของดูสีสีน้ำตาลมีสีน้ำตาลสีน้ำตาล
ก็ต้องเป็นสัตว์บกค่ะใส่ค่ะหมีเป็นสัตว์
บกเป็นสัตว์บกนะคะ
ครูเอ๋คะสัตว์ตัวนี้เรียกว่าอะไรคะแม่
อา
กะพรุน
แมงกะพรุนแมงกะพรุน
แมงกะพรุนเป็นสัตว์บกหรือสัตว์น้ำ
เองแมงกระพรุนสีฟ้าโอเค
สัตว์น้ำค่ะเดี๋ยว
เทคนิคครูเอ๋ก็คือดูว่าสัตว์สีอะไรไอ้คิว
นิดหน่อย
แมงกะพรุนเป็นสัตว์น้ำ
น้ำน้ำใส่น้ำทะเลค่ะ
ครูเอ๋มีมีอีกไหมคะมีเข็ม
สัตว์ตัวนี้เรียกว่าอะไรคะเออเอ่อคนไทย
เนี่ยจะพูดปลาดาวน้ำมาดาวแต่ว่าบางคนก็
พูดดาวทะเล
พูดดาวทะเลอ่ะดาวทะเลโอเค
ซุปเปอร์คิงส์ป้องแต่คนไทยจะพูดปลาดาว
ลาดาว
ปลาดาวเป็นปลาก็อยู่ในน้ำปลาดาวเป็นสัตว์
บกหรือสัตว์น้ำคะครูเอ๋สีน้ำตาลเนาะติด
น้ำตาลอยู่บนบก
แต่ปลาดาวไม่อยู่บนบกประดาวอยู่ในน้ำนะคะ
อยู่ในก็เป็นสัตว์น้ำค่ะปลาดาวเป็นสระตาม
ให้ค่ะรูปต่อไปค่ะครูเองอะไรคะสัตว์ตัว
นี้เรียกว่าอะไรคะเต่าค่ะอ่ะเกาะเต่าเป็น
สัตว์บบหรือสัตว์น้ำคะครูเอ๋เอ๋คิ้วอัน
นี้
หน้ากูอีกคิด
เต่าอยู่บนบกได้ไหมได้อยู่ในน้ำได้ไหมได้
งั้นเต่า
เหมือนกบไหมคะเฮ้ยเป่ากบเหมือนกันอยู่ใน
น้ำได้อยู่บนบกได้อะแล้วเรา
เก่าก็เป็นสัตว์ครึ่ง
บกครึ่งน้ำ
ใช่ใส่ 3 เป็นสัตว์ครึ่ง rebow เร่งน้ำ
เต่าวิ่งเร็วๆใช่ไหมคะพี่ใช่แบบอ่ะช่วง
เนี้ยเดินช้าๆ
ช้าช้าๆป่าช้า
เร็วนะคะไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่เร็วๆค่ะ
[เพลง]
น้องเต่ากบน้องไม่ใช่สัตว์บกไม่ใช่สัตว์
น้ำมาเป็นสัตว์ครึ่งบกครึ่งน้ำนะคะ
ต่อไปค่ะ
มีฆ่าสัตว์ตัวนี้เรียกว่าอะไรคะเดี๋ยวผู้
หญิงสีฟ้า
เอาชื่อก่อนค่ะครูเองตัวเองคิดอย่างเดียว
สีอะไร
อา
ปลา
กระเบนอาจใช่ค่ะปลากระเบนอะนี้เราเรียก
อะไรคะครูเอ๋หางค่ะหายหางเหมือน
ก็เหมือนหนีเมียคะหมีก็มีหางสั้นๆ
เมื่อกี้คุยดูนะคุยกับผิดอะไรก็ไม่เอาสี
ฟ้าก่อน
เหมือนกล้วยอีกอะไรมันข้างไหนข้างบนอัน
ไหนข้างล่าง
ครูเอ๋คะปลากระเบนเป็นสัตว์บกหรือสัตว์
น้ำสีฟ้าค่ะสร้างป่าวสัตว์น้ำหาเป็นสัตว์
น้ำชัยค่ะเป็นสัตว์น้ำค่ะ
มีอีกไหมคะนี่ค่ะนี้อะไรมาเอ้าสัตว์ตัว
นี้เรียกว่าอะไรคะขอโทษนะคะ
แรดค่ะตีสัตว์ค่ะและนะรถมีอะไรคะตรงนี้
เห็นปากผู้หญิงไว้ข้างๆหน้าคุณหญิงโอเค
แรดมีอะไรคะมีนอหนูมีน้อ
นอนออน
ไม่ใช่เขาไม่ใช่ค่ะแล้วครูเอ๋บอกว่าแพะมี
เขาค่ะ
แต่แรดมีนอให้คอ่าครูเอ๋คะแรดเป็นสัตว์บก
หรือสัตว์น้ำแรดเป็นสัตว์เด็กค่ะสีน้ำตาล
นะไม่ใช่สีน้ำตาโบะอันนี้น้ำ
เป็นน้ำ
เป็นสัตว์บกขาใส่วันนี้เนี่ยนักเรียน
นักเรียนก็ได้รู้จักสัตว์บกใช่ไหมคะการ
ประปาสัตว์น้ำอะไรคะสัตว์บบกับสัตว์น้ำ
อีกถูกหูสัตว์น้ำเยอะจังค่ะ
แล้วก็ครึ่งบกครึ่งน้ำหนักไรค่ะอันนี้ก็
คือสัตว์บกชนะคะผู้หญิงสัตว์บกมีอะไรบ้าง
คะสัตว์บกมีแพ้ค่ะ 1 แพะ 2
แรด
3 หมา 4
หมี 5
สิงโต 6 เสือ 7 วัว
มี 7 ตัวนะคะสัตว์บกสัตว์น้ำมีอะไรบ้างคะ
เล็กปลากระเบนเป่ากระเบน 2
ปลาดาวหรือ
เสือดาวทะเลใช่ไหมคะปลาดาวหรือดาวทะเลสาบ
แมงกะพรุนแต่งกับรุน 4 ลาโลมาปลาโลมาค่า
ปลาหมึกยักษ์น้ำหมึกยักษ์
กุ้ง
กุ้งช้างบทกุ้งนาภาษาไทย
7 ปลาฉลามปลาฉลาม 8 น้าน้ำมะนาวน้ำ 9 มี
ไหมหมดแล้ว 8 แล้วครึ่งบกครึ่งน้ำครึ่งบก
ครึ่งน้ำ
มีอะไร
มีเต่าอ่ะหนึ่งเต่า
2 กบกบนะคะค้างถ้าเก้าสิบอยู่อยู่ในน้ำ
ได้อยู่บนบกได้
นะคะวันนี้นักเรียนก็รู้จักสัตว์บกสัตว์
น้ำสัตว์ครึ่งบกครึ่งน้ำ
เราก็รู้จักสัตว์มากๆนะคะใครค่ะรู้จักวะ
น้องวีดีโอนี้หมดเวลาแล้วนะครับรูหญิงกับ
ครูเอกก็ต้องไปก่อนค่ะ
แล้วเจอกันวีดีโอหน้านะคะบ๊ายบายสวัสดี
ค่ะอ่ะ